diese szene beschreibt das komplette
spiel eigentlich hallo mein name ist
luca und herzlich willkommen zu einem
spiel das bescheuerte eigentlich gar
nicht sein kann wir haben hier ein handy
und fahrrad in diesem spiel jeder frosch
ein handy um mit diesem handy hier
können wir verschiedene sachen machen
wir können es die kontrollen schauen wir
können alles möglich machen wir haben
auch fnn news scheiß auf cnn
egal wir haben fnn und das hier sind wir
freunde wir sind ein frosch und können
das ist das ist das sind spiele die ich
wirklich respektiere wir können ja sogar
mit dem frosch über den boden gleiten
aber wir können auch aufstehen das hier
ist die steuerung was sagst du dazu
sehe ich genauso ich laufe jetzt einfach
mal zu diesen dingen hebt das mal hoch
und ihr seht schon dass wir sind ja
meine freunde das heißt er habe ich
würde sagen hey freunde wenn wir unten
noch einen fußball wie kann man den
fußball nehmen und jetzt muss ich den
fußball mal wollt ihr mal irgendwas was
ist das passiert was ist das für ein
spiel wir schauen uns einfach mal ein
bisschen hier oben wir haben hier
irgendwie so ein parcours wir haben hier
so genau hier vorne haben wir ein tor
und das tor kann hochfahren und die
laufen
jetzt gerade fragt mich bitte nicht was
das für ein spiele freunde ich weiß es
selbst nicht
und es ist noch überhaupt nicht fertig
wir sind anscheinend jetzt hier in der
freien welt angekommen
du solltest darunter alter freunde wir
brauchen unbedingt einen namen für
diesen frosch wie kommst du es nicht
über diese absperrung
wir brauchen den namen für diesen tag
frosch ich bin für fuhr sie gegen die
rockets grad ein bisschen das liegt
nicht an meiner pc leistung sondern das
liegt tatsächlich am spiel oh mein gott
hallo wer bist du denn da kennen wir uns
herr kollege bleibt einmal stehen hier
komme ich bin ich ich würde dich einfach
vorzieht das war ein freund von uns ich
kann den typen hier tatsächlich
mitnehmen und jetzt laufe ich mal auf
die dga r stolpert über ein scheiß
bordstein ich versuche jetzt mal in der
ohl das tut mir leid falls es die krisen
dieser frosch ist echt am arsch alter
schaut mich noch gegen einen bordstein
und er fällt hin die ja was ist los mit
diesen kummer jetzt so weit was macht er
dann mit dem auto was ich weiß nicht was
seine aufgabe da hinten im spiel ist ich
schaue mal ob wir uns irgendwie ein auto
gönnen können also nicht wahr wir müssen
unbedingt unseren freund von vorhin
wieder einfangen das war auf jeden fall
so ein komischer typ der
mit einem schild herumgefahren ist
herumgelaufen ist wo es ist ein
draufsteht labor der iss drei kollegen
hier kann ich irgendwie hupen
nee das war die bremse voll nice alter
erfährt einfach ein mini ich war auch im
mini also es passt perfekt jetzt kollege
bleibt doch mal stehen jetzt verdammte
kacke ja ich will mich doch nur abholen
alt da komm wir stellen einfach die pink
ab da kann genau so steigt man den autos
ein schreibt mir auf jeden fall wenn die
kommentare wie ihr den von toy story wie
er den frosch ihn nennen würde kommt
sogar genau die gleiche farbe wie unser
auto unser kennzeichen ist schirmer also
nahm fürs auto habe ich schon mal um mal
die ganze szenerie hier gerade zu
beschreiben
wir befinden uns sowohl in einem
riesigen trakt vielleicht eingefangen
worden von menschen oder irgendwie so
wir haben hier in fußballplatz können
hier an der seite umfang irgendwie alle
autos sind minis ich weiß ja auch diese
spielen eine partnerschaft mit mini hat
ich denke nicht weil dieses spiel
eigentlich total beschissen ist aber
irgendwie sind wir eingesperrt
irgendwie ist dieses spiel total
bescheuert ich habe ein reifen in der
hand und läuft jetzt um ein komplettes
auto da hinten ist dies bond frogs
center ich weiß nicht ob ich mir das
gerade noch ein wilder irgendwie läuft
ja gerade schneller also keine ahnung
immer wieder schneller läuft furz der
vision haben uns jetzt einfach mal
dieses auto hier vorne
du musst nur einsteigen eine ewigkeit
später
willst du dich vielleicht mal nach vorne
setzen letzte freunde unser mini ist war
dies bond weil wir den unfall gebaut
haben aber hiermit können wir immer noch
irgendwelche konstanz versuchen das
heißt ja toll dieses falls diese szene
beschreibt das komplette spiel
eigentlich wenn wir da jetzt theoretisch
mal hingehen und dieses schwein einfach
mal schüler
ja
das hat definitiv funktioniert ich weiß
nicht was man mit diesem schweinchen
machen kann also ob das einfach nur hier
nicht im ernst ich mit diesem schweine
jetzt wisst ihr
nee nee bis sie gerade wo ich dieses
video aufnehmen als die halbzeitpause
zwischen dortmund gegen bayern bayern
führt gerade 20 100 champions league und
wissen was ich hier mache ist ja auch
komplett egal ich will auf jeden fall
nicht mehr mit diesem schweine irgendwie
zusammen arbeiten und dieser forsch ist
doch auch voll am arsch eigentlich ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt wirklich nicht was
der sinn von diesem spiel ist es da
vorne an dem hochhaus ist auf jeden fall
eine zeichnung von unserer fresse hier
vorne haben wir gegen so einen
aufsitzrasenmäher nie rassist nicht ich
sondern das ist dass irgend so ein
schaeffler oder keine ahnung aber sowas
nennt man hier wird jetzt einfach mal
unsere freunde abholen also wir vorne so
scheiß auf freunde alter wir haben uns
einen frog mit coffee genau so steigt
man ab ja schönen guten tag herr frau
frosch das sind tolle bewegungen die
wieder machen
ich hätte gerne was zu essen du hast es
nicht gott wirklich im volk mit kaffee
gefurzt wir haben leider noch keine
credits das heißt ich glaube ich kann
mir ja you don't have enough reward
points to get this project ab und
premium great café okay ich weiß noch
gar nicht was ich jemand jetzt irgendwie
machen soll ich kann auf controls
klicken aber eigentlich gibt es ja fast
gar nix ich suche jetzt mal eine
freundin für ihn hier also hey wer ist
sie denn
hallo kann ich mit dir irgendwie
irgendwas kann ich mit dir gehen
ich versteh ich verstehe gar nichts mehr
jetzt da du meine frau kommt nicht so
richtig in eis gefunden hat würde ich
sagen ich schenk dir einfach mal ein
klopapier maxi anscheinend auch nicht so
gerne schnell weglaufen bevor sie uns
doch irgendwie verfolgt
ja ich drück nichts hey dude wurde das
war ich nicht falls es übrigens nicht
gesehen habe freunde ich habe hier nur
menschen leisten ihr seht schon da steht
nur gut drauf
das launch am 11 12 ich bin echt
gespannt ob man hier mit jetzt irgendwie
bei degen eine rampe druck
ich bin in bordstein hochgefahren hier
vorne ist irgendwie ein geheimgang also
man kann jetzt hier durchlaufen ich
glaube da hinten befindet sich ein lkw
es hat auch kein lkw sondern ein bus
meine freunde also ich gehe nähere mich
einfach mal den bus versuchen es mit dem
bus mal hier vielleicht in die garage
rein zu fahren vielleicht kann man da
etwas cooles machen also wir schauen mal
halle ein kaktus simulators nix hier
gegen die holen jetzt unsere frosch
freunde ab und mache mit ihnen ein
ausflug da vorne ist wieder eine person
mit einem schild das heißt ich würde
sagen wir holen als erstes mal sie hier
vorne ab das ist uns glaube ich nicht
realisiert vielleicht einfach mal so ein
bisschen hierhin hashtag ein du machst
hey du machst bus kaputt da die keiner
geben die einsteigen würde ich sagen
haben unsere eigenen hund katze jetzt
bei aufhören da vorne auch cool dass
unser schwein mittlerweile schon da
vorne vergammelt raum schongau ist das
musste doch wohl schaffen hier sollen
berghoch alter wir haben auch nicht
umsonst so viel kraft in dieser liga ich
gebe vollgas gibt wirklich vollgas
scheißer vorwärtsfahren alter welcher
mensch muss vorwärts fahren dennoch
einfach rückwärts fahren können also ich
will jetzt einfach unsere gäste mal
rückwärts auf die lenkung ist auch viel
besser wenn wir einfach rückwärts fahren
ich sehe hier vorne haben wir eine rampe
das heißt versuche es mal über die rampe
drüber mit dem ballast main post in ruhe
ich las den bus da vorne einfach mal
stehen der schon genug ärger bereitet
und jetzt werde ich einfach mal mit
einer anderen karte zum beispiel mit dem
mini da vorne mensch der mit dem mini
werde ich jetzt in den bus rein fahren
und mal schauen was passiert es ist
nicht unser mini von gerade da hatten
wir ja ein anderes kennzeichen aber ich
werde jetzt einfach mal versuchen in dem
bus nach vorne rein zu fahren also von
hinten schön warm
diese spielen bereitet mir irgendwie in
höllenspaß allein dass gerade ich wollte
einfach loslaufen der typ fällt hin und
fuhr zu das ist einfach mein leben als
spiel ich will auch immer loslaufen fall
hin und füttern wir haben wir auf jeden
fall noch unglaublich viele sachen zu
entdecken also haben dahin genau vor
zuerst mal wir haben da hinten noch eine
rampe wir haben hier vorne noch gebäuden
die wir rein können ich habe da hinten
um die ecke glaube ich irgendwo sogar
noch genau dahin ist noch ein
schachbrett aufgebaut und wir sind auch
gerade nur in diese welt hinein gegangen
also ich glaube waren zu beginnen da
oben drin das heißt vielleicht gibt es
auch noch irgendwelche anderen welten
ich weiß es nicht
das spiel heißt der mäßigen frog falls
ihr dazu irgendwelche ideen aber was ich
noch machen könnte ich habe bisher
eigentlich fast gar nichts gemacht
schreibt zwar und in die kommentare und
sonst nicht an der stelle das heutige
video jetzt auch beenden ich hoffe es
nicht gefallen wenn sie das getan hat
was man gern ein leichter und schreibt
mir die kommentare wenn ihr jetzt noch
dran seit wir den forschenden würde ich
also vorzieht
das ist mein vorschlag aber vielleicht
habt ihr bessere vorschläge und sonst
meine damen und herren will ich jetzt
sagen konnte nun mit zu dem punkt an in
diesem video worauf ich wirklich die
meisten leute freuen und der einzige
grund war was ist das da vorne
eigentlich so ein komischer spaßt jetzt
kommt das auto also die autogas ziel das
was jetzt hier vom video hier können
jetzt hier in einen kanal abonnieren
oder
meinen job aus checken jetzt findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]